big big big thing I build Legos I don't
play with Legos um but second of all
yeah all the time bro I got I got a lot
of um that's literally all I do in my
downtime I get back to the crib you know
I just kind of just it's a way for me to
I take my mind off of things you know
I'll U put some music on and I might put
put a show on or something like that but
at least three four hours on my day bro
like I'm putting stuff together I've
already built 12 different projects I
mean I've counted up everything I've
gone through 120,000 Legos just um since
the season started itself but I mean uh
you you know y'all see that when y'all
see I'll put that little content out
there for you